what's
shaking people i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report direct message
for december 16th 2020
lots going on in the world we're gonna
bounce all over the place with the
stories today
a little bit a little bit of election
stuff biden stuff that sort of thing a
little bit about
some sellout lincoln project republicans
a little bit about social
justice we'll mix some fun stuff in
there and before i get to any of that
though
uh i just want to thank all you who
joined us for the reuben report
community
movie night last night we had an
absolutely great time so if you didn't
join us
we watch v for vendetta which is just a
spectacular movie
uh that is so relevant like deeply
deeply relevant to everything that's
going on in the world right now the
movie came out in 2005. it's obviously
the story of guy fawkes from
way before that but there's so many
relevant points about a pandemic about
overreaching government
about bravery and how it's on you to fix
things and and ideas versus people
and you can kill people but you can't
kill ideas it was just great
so we did a netflix party so we were
live chatting with people text chat
during the movie
and then we did a huge group zoom after
where we had 100 people i didn't realize
we could only get 100 people in there so
we had 100 people
all on video chatting afterwards which
was awesome and we're going to expand
that so we can do more than 100 people
so i apologize if you weren't able to
get in we maxed out at 100 there was
nothing we could do
and by the way we in the locals app
which i hope most of you have at this
point
we are working on building out live
video we have live chat in there right
now but soon enough we won't be relying
on
zoom either uh and just one more good
note before we jump into it uh yesterday
was
our biggest day of growth on
reubenreport.com
since we relaunched the site and and
partnered up with locals and all that
well i
guess not partnered up i i kind of built
locals with some people but
uh yeah there we go uh so lots of good
things are happening and i'm feeling i'm
feeling good about the world
uh despite the craziness uh before we
get to all the stories though guys i
want to talk to you about glint pay you
know the holidays are coming it's nine
days away from christmas
it is night six night six or seven of
hanukkah right now
and uh i hope you're you're buying some
gifts i hope i hope you got a couple
bucks in your pocket and you're able to
to spread the love with family and
friends and if you are buying anything
this holiday season
you can use your glint card it's a great
way to get into the gold game as i've
been talking about
you can buy and sell gold using their
app and then you can make
purchases using their mastercard with
either
gold or us dollars you can use it just
like a credit card it's pretty fantastic
the glenn card is issued by sutton bank
member fdic
pursuant to license from mastercard
international
it's free to sign up so go to
glintpay.com reuben for more information
and to start
purchasing gold today that's
glintpay.com ruben to get your gold
today
and now back to me uh you know just one
other thing on gold you know
diversifying your
your financial portfolio is obviously
important and if i'm not mistaken i just
saw that
even today bitcoin just cracked 20 grand
i've got a couple a couple bitcoin just
sitting around i'm just going to sit on
them for now
we'll see what happens but it's good to
see people are kind of thinking about
things a little bit
a little bit differently these days okay
so let's talk about the election uh as
i've been saying to you guys i get
that according to the way the system
works at the moment that joe biden
is the is the president-elect he has an
office of the
president-elect and this morning he was
talking about the wonderfully diverse
cabinet the most diverse cabinet
that he's putting out there obviously
his buddy barack obama was a racist
bigot
and a homophobe and a transphobe and the
rest of it and didn't do any of those
things so
joe is a better man than barack obama
and apparently got 16.1 million more
votes than barack obama that utter
failure
hope and change guess it didn't work um
well joe biden
uh who again i guess is the
president-elect there's still some
things working through the courts
sydney powell is still working on the
dominion stuff we shall
see that's what i've said from the
beginning and that's what i will
continue to say
until it's all over at the end and at
the end if we get
to january 20th and biden is sworn in i
am a loyal american citizen and uh
i will be i will accept that we have a
guy in office that i'm not really into
and that is you know the leader of the
party that has all the horrific ideas
that i've been fighting against for five
years but i'll accept it and you know
what i won't burn down a
target that's my commitment to you if
joe biden is president
on january 20th i won't burn down a
target i won't burn down a pep boys
and i won't burn down a best buy that is
my commitment to you as an american
citizen that's the type
of goodness that we bring here at the
reuben report
but let's back up for just a second
because i saw this video on twitter
yesterday and it's pretty interesting
because right now
we're basically being told by mainstream
media that you can't talk about voter
fraud right
absolutely nothing happened there was no
issue with mail-in ballots there's no
issue with the dominion software there's
no issue
with people flipping votes there's no
issue with the mail-in stuff there's no
issue anywhere all the signed affidavits
forget all that okay blah blah blah
we can't even talk about it and if you
talk about it you're basically framed as
if
as if you're crazy you're alex jones
you're a conspiracy theorist you're a
deplorable you're a bad guy and the rest
of it
well you're not going to believe this
guys but this video popped up
from 2007 and here's joe biden
in 2007 13 years ago when he was running
for president so if you don't remember
he actually ran for president against
barack obama
way back in 2007 as a democrat and he
didn't make it very far he was in a
couple
a couple debates and i kind of liked him
at the time actually i thought he was
more of like a bit of a centrist
democrat but here's joe biden back in
2007
talking about voter fraud now the second
piece you're talking about
which is what people usually mean by
election reform how you're going to keep
it from
us being able to be in a position where
you can manipulate the machines
manipulate the records the one way to do
that is
i think we should pass a federal law
mandating that
the same machines with paper trails be
mandatory for every federal election
that will be a multi-billion dollar bill
for the states because the states will
have to make a choice then
they will have to make a choice whether
or not they have two machines
we can't mandate as you know state
elections we can't tell the state of
delaware or ohio
or texas what machines and what method
they use to vote in their state
elections but we can do it federally
so in a nutshell i think we should be
mandated mandating
that we have a paper ballot with a
standardized machine
standardized requirements
well you heard it there first joe biden
2007
mandating standardized machines with a
paper trail
oddly if you were to even say that now
you would be told
that you're a nut but you're a nut job
you're a nut bag i was gonna say nut job
and nut bag you'd be told that you were
either a nut job or a nut bag
okay uh this this is a problem because
we
all know every one of us knows that we
should have sort of
basic requirements for our voting
integrity right a paper trail would be a
good idea
making sure we have secure software
would be a good idea i don't even
believe by the way that there's anything
that would leave us with a perfect
system you guys know how i feel about
that i don't think you can build perfect
systems i think humans
are are fallible and can only build
fallible things but you can build things
that are certainly better than the
things that we've got
but we're now not even allowed to talk
about that in 2020 without being told
that we're conspiracy theorists of
course if you're a conspiracy theorist
you you might find this video
interesting this is just days
before the election in 2020 when joe
biden told us about the
voter fraud organization that he was
leading secondly
we're in a situation where we have put
together
and you guys did it for our
administration the president
obama's administration before this we
have put together
i think the most extensive
and inclusive voter fraud
organization in the history of american
politics
what what now the most extensive and
inclusive voter fraud organization in
the history of american politics i'm
glad it's inclusive
it's one thing to be extensive like
we're doing an extensive
voter fraud situation but it should also
be inclusive you know what i mean let's
make sure
we've got a couple lesbians with limps
and people with lazy eyes
and uh you know a couple couple trans
people with big feet if
you've got that then we're inclusive
we're good to go now obviously he just
mangled what he was saying there or
you know one of the side effects of
dementia
of cognitive problems is that you start
accidentally saying what the truth is
because your systems basically are
breaking down the walls that would allow
you to lie are basically breaking down
in your mind
and everything he says is this muddled
mess when he's reading on the prompter
it's a muddled mess he can
somehow sometimes kind of get it and
then go with it but he he
mumbles through most of it and when he's
actually going off the cuff like that
he's telling you about the largest voter
fraud organization
in american history and it's inclusive
people uh
look obviously it's it's just a fumbling
of of words there which is a problem
unto itself but let's put that aside for
a second the point is
that in 2007 this guy was was saying the
truth the stuff that we know
i'm not even totally convinced you need
a federal
law that would say that every state has
to do it exactly the same way i'm not
even totally sure of that
but i think that there maybe could be
some basic federal guidelines
and by the way we have some of this
stuff but the simple fact is
on november 3rd of this year i walked
into a polling place in los angeles
i did not show my id i told them my
address
it was actually my old address and my
and my name
and then i went to vote i could have
literally gone
back hours later and said that i was my
neighbor because i know his name and his
address
and the idea that the system isn't being
taken advantage of and by the way i've
heard many many versions of this
but the idea that you don't even need an
id to vote in some states is
truly crazy the only way that you would
be for not
having ids be mandated to vote would be
if you want
to rig the system right that that is it
do you believe do you person watching
this right now do you believe you should
have to have an id to get on a plane
i do i do i think and by the way you do
right
you do to get past tsa and then you show
your your little
qr code and do you have to have an id to
buy a beer
okay you have to have an id when you go
to a bar we used to go to bars back in
the day i'm old school
now you just sit at home and drink alone
depressed in the basement
but the idea is that if we have ideas to
do some things
if this is our greatest civic duty is if
this is the thing that democracy hinges
upon then perhaps we should have to have
ids
and i do want to just say one other
thing because i think this shows a
little bit
of the sexism of mainstream media
if you look at joe biden in 2007 versus
joe biden now it is very obvious that
he's had at least a facelift he's got a
ton of botox and fillers and the rest of
it you know he's got these crazy
lines up here because they pulled the
face back he's got hair plugs and the
rest of it i don't care about any of
that and i don't begrudge anyone doing
whatever the hell they want to do i
really don't
but when i saw that video it did strike
me because it's like if he was a woman
people would be talking about this all
the time everyone would be joking about
it
everyone would be mocking it and
everything else but somehow
with a man it gets weird like you can't
really talk about it but he's done he's
done some weird stuff to his
spaces it's just
just right but also the voter fraud
thing so anyway
all right let's talk about built bar
people are you looking for a new protein
bar that tastes like a candy bar i know
you are
well i've i've got just the brand for
you and i've got several of them
right here people built bars are super
tasty and come in 18 amazing flavors
i've got raspberry here i've got cookies
and cream i've got coconut almond
and i've got banana bread all right my
personal favorite egg as you guys know
is the cookies and cream built bars are
covered in 100
chocolate include both nut and nut free
flavors and are soft and easy to chew
with the holidays just around the corner
it's easy to slip up which is why built
bars are the perfect
alternative to pie for the health
conscious guy
i can actually lose or maintain weight
while indulging in a delicious treat
built bars are low calorie low sugar
high protein and high fiber
go to builtbar.com and use promo code
ruben and you'll get 20
off your first order use promo code
ruben for 20 off at billboard.com good
for bars
built go or bill boost and now back to
me
all right so the second story i wanted
to talk to you about it's sort of
election
related uh is about this gop strategist
this long-time republican strategist you
may know his name if you're
in the political mix but you may not if
you're just a good decent human being
who isn't obsessed with this stuff but
this is an interesting story
long time gop strategist steve schmidt
has announced that he's registering
as a democrat now if you don't know
steve schmidt he was the co-founder of
project lincoln and project lincoln was
a bunch of these never trump
republican losers who basically are all
democrats
they're just all democrats and i want to
say something here i get
that a lot of people don't like trump i
had all sorts of reservations
about trump for a long time that i
expressed on this show and the tweeting
and the way he speaks and
okay fine so i understand that you could
be a republican or you could be a
democrat
and not like trump obviously and i also
believe that we live in a free country
where you should make whatever choice
you think is best for you and your
family and the rest of it
but these these odd never trump
conservatives they created this thing
called lincoln project they got
a ton of money okay a ton of money and
this guy's one of the co-founders
they poured a ton of money into all
these races and if i'm not mistaken
every race that they poured money into
uh down ticket in this last election
they lost which is pretty fantastic so
they just piss away money these people
they make money you know it's a
non-profit lincoln project but one of
the things that people don't understand
about nonprofits is you can obviously
pay your employees so these guys make a
[ __ ] ton of money
okay they they screw up everything they
harm the republicans they don't even win
their races
and now this clown has decided that he's
a democrat it's also very obvious
because it's one thing say 20 years ago
20 30 years ago
if you said i'm a republican but i don't
like what's going on with republicans
i'm a democrat well at that time the
parties had
some sort of commonalities right like
they were you know obviously if
republicans a little more
it's a little more right let's say i was
losing this hand but it's a little more
right
maybe it's a little more for states
rights hopefully some lower taxes stuff
like that
and if you're left you're a little more
for big government you want the
government to do more things federal
government okay
but the cu but there was a sort of
belief like oh we both believe in the
system we both believe that america is
good we believe in the
founding of our nation as a
fundamentally positive thing
where now it's very obvious that on the
left that
concept has been completely decimated so
it's very
strange to me that an adult could go
from being a republican despite the
frustrations that you might have with
mitch mcconnell with donald trump
with the the fact that the republicans
don't really do anything right they had
a ton of time to do something about big
tech they did jack [ __ ]
so i get it i get it i'm not telling you
these people are great i happen to
really like ted cruz i happen to like
rand paul but i'm not telling you these
people are all great but the idea that
you'd go okay i'm
i have this basic set of beliefs which i
assume
includes being pro-life and and a bunch
of other things that are thought of as
conservative values
and now i'm going to move as an adult to
the democratic position which now is
basically
let's destroy the system big government
for everything let's raise taxes
nine month abortions like the series of
crazy things that the democrats have now
become
it just doesn't make sense to me as an
adult you know one of the things people
talk about
what's the line i think is it from
chamberlain about if you're in your 20s
and you're not a liberal you don't have
a heart and if you're in your 30s and
you're conservative you don't have a
brain
it's something like that that as time
goes by you should you
in essence should become more
conservative because you realize there
were good
things before you the idea that people
go the other way
especially as we're watching the left go
off the deep end seems very bizarre to
me but we're going to read a quote
from steve schmidt himself well-paid and
well-fed steve schmidt
he says i spent 29 years as a republican
i've spent two and a half as an
independent
and later this afternoon i will register
as a member of the democratic party
because in america today it's the it's
only the democratic party which is the
oldest political party in the world
that stands for the ideas and the ideals
of american liberty i mean
that's such bananas horse poop that i
don't even know where to start with that
the democratic party
stands for the ideas and ideals of
american liberty that's crazy
there's nothing about liberty or freedom
or state's rights or personal
responsibility or defending the first
amendment or the second amendment or the
fourth amendment
as we have lockdowns uh that has
anything to do with the democratic party
the democratic party stands for giant
government period
giant government and were all racists
and this country was founded on evil
and if you thought joe biden was the guy
that was going to stop that thing
i got another thing coming i just
watched a video this morning where
pete buddha judge is going to be the
transportation secretary he has no
expertise in this as i said yesterday
but he is gay so that's spectacular
at least he got the the road guy is gay
that's very important
um but he's talking about systemic
racism in roads these people
are children larping as adults if you
don't know what larping is google it
there's a lot of funny videos of people
larping but that's what they are they
are children larping as adults who know
what they're doing
uh but this steve schmidt guy the real
reason i know him is because for years i
watched the bill maher show and i'd
still love to chat with bill maher
because i think bill maher is basically
a good liberal he's lost it a little bit
with trump derangement syndrome i know
that the producers of your show watch my
show all the time and then repeat a lot
of the stuff that i say
on on his show and i know that i'm
talked about in the meetings i have my
ways
but schmidt goes on bill maher all the
time and
one of the things that happens to these
republicans that suddenly say oh i'm a
good guy i'm a democrat i'm leaving the
republican well what happens you get on
tv like nobody's business you'll be on
bill maher and msnbc and nbc
and abc and cbs they'll put you on
everything in cnn
you're a good guy now sure we said you
were evil and
awful and horrific and hitler a couple
years ago i mean look
look at mitt romney mitt romney is now a
hero of the left right because he's an
anti-trump republican
because the the trump republicans for
whatever flaws they may have
at least they can get it up but the
these other guys are just a bunch of
flaccid losers i mean that really is
just how it is
i i see it no other way but but schmidt
goes on bill maher all the time
let's take a look at schmidt on bill
maher when he was a republican i suppose
or i guess he maybe was an independent
at this point but he was running
something called lincoln project
which was for never trump republicans uh
2018.
i hear this all the time that because
trump's numbers within the party are so
high it's because the actual number of
republicans
are going down it always makes me want
to ask you how many steve schmitz
are out there how many people in the
republican party or who used to be
who are now switching i think it's a
very significant number
and i think you're going to see
college-educated republican women in
these swing districts deliver the blue
wave for the democrats because
i think there are many many people have
left but but the future of the national
republican party looks exactly like the
future of the california gop which
for the first time in history of the two
parties in any state
the republican party in this state is
now a third party it's smaller than the
decline of state registrations
when you look at the anathema uh uh that
that that millennials feel towards the
republican party you look at
african-americans brown people you look
at just demographically the country and
you consider that
when people in print on a political
party generationally
at 18 years age they remain faithful to
that party
really for their lifetimes for for
decades and decades and decades so the
republican party sometimes has a huge
huge huge problem demographically and
it's going to continue to shrink but as
it gets shrinker
as it shrinks it gets smaller just like
the california republican party has
it will become crazier okay so you can
see there he he kind of is rooting for
the failure of the republicans i don't
even want to get lost in what he said i
thought the line from bill maher
was so interesting there though because
bill maher goes how many steve schmitz
are there
the implication being oh you're a good
pet republican and if there were only
more of
you who would always lose and who would
never fight for what you believe in and
who would always behave
more like us well then we put you on tv
more i mean that really is what this all
boils down to but again the the big
idea here the main point of this thing
is that this ain't 30 years ago this
ain't oh you know i've decided i don't
like
bob dole so i'm going to vote for bill
clinton
something like that right like they kind
of both believe in the fundamental
principles of america that this thing is
pretty good
this is now in effect like oh i don't
like
trump so and he says mean things even
though he put
conservative judges on and defended the
pro-life position
and which by the way i'm pro-choice i
mean you guys know that and i get a lot
of [ __ ] for it
so i'm not even saying that all these
ideas are the better ideas but the point
is
that that if you're as an adult if
you're now moving that way
it strikes me as some sort of brain
damage but maybe they'll look into that
maybe it's a
symptom of coronavirus i don't know all
right let's talk about
title lock before i jump into the third
story uh you know i got a crash course
in home title theft a couple days ago i
talked to the title lock guys
and you better pray that this never
happens to you because it can ruin you
financially
here's basically what happens the legal
titles to our home are kept online where
they can be hacked we've all got a
title to our home a cyber thief finds
your home's title
forges your signature on a quit claim
deed stating that you sold your home to
him
then he takes out loans against your
home until your equity
is gone you won't know until that
collection call
starts pouring in you're not protected
by insurance your bank or common
identity theft programs home title lock
protects you
and in the unlikely event you become a
victim of title
theft while a member home title lock
will spend up to a quarter million
dollars
in legal fees to help restore your
home's title go to home
hometitlelock.com and register your
address to see if you're already a
victim
then use code ruben for 30 free days of
protection
that's code rubin no they're telling me
code radio all right let's use code
radio why not people
they trust me all right go to
hometitlelock.com and use code radio
and now back to me there we go all right
that's pretty good i thought it was code
rubin but we're going with code radio
fair enough
we are a podcast that is a form of audio
medium which is
uh commonly thought of as radio okay
let's do segment three here
uh this one almost had me punching
somebody yesterday i almost punched the
dog when i read this story
it's an odd thing it's like i'm sitting
next to the dog and i felt like i needed
to punch somebody but i don't hit my dog
but this one could have got me there
because it's so ridiculous
the new york city teachers union which
is basically just a mafia organization
at this point
has passed a black lives matter
at school resolution let's go directly
to the quote from the united
federation of teachers black villages
we are committed to disrupting the
western prescribed nuclear family
structure
requirement by supporting each other as
extended families and villages
that collectively care for one another
and especially
our children to the degree that mothers
parents
and children are comfortable uh okay
i want to be very clear about this i
don't like you people
and uh we are working at having kids
okay
and you will never have anything to do
with my children i don't live in new
york city but this
this cancer this perverse parasite of
social justice and this black lives
matter nonsense
is spreading into all of our public
education and when i saw this
story yesterday the first thing that i
tweeted out was
if you have the means you now must it is
on you as a free thinking
person if if you have any
desire to to continue living as a free
human
you got to get your kids out of public
school now you got to get them out now
because if you think this is going to
sit and only happen
in in new york city this is going to
happen everywhere
some of the language in there is just
horrible they're not our children
they're not our children i'm i'm
nobody's parent yet
when i become a parent that will be my
child the idea that we have these
collective
children is uh is deeply scary and also
destroy the nuclear family
you know this is the type of stuff that
some people on the right were talking
about years ago the attack on the family
right
and they were told that they were bigots
and racists and all of these and the
usual
stuff and what has happened as has as
happens in almost every occasion now
they've been proven right
there is a plan by black lives matters
which is a self-described marxist
organization
to destroy the nuclear family meaning a
mom a dad
and some kids now i would like to expand
the definition of that meaning
i don't care if you have two fathers or
two mothers and it's a loving family and
all of those things
and i'm happy to have that conversation
with my more conservative friends who
mostly agree with me by the way on that
uh but putting that part aside the idea
of the family structure
the idea of the family structure when i
was on torah jordan this was one of the
things jordan peterson of course this
was one of the things that he talked
about a lot
that the family structure that you have
two parents and they
come together to create a parental unit
that then can teach
sort of the the history of the world the
values give purpose to children
hopefully
hopefully take some of the stuff that
they've learned from their parents and
the generations before them
and hand it down that's a very intrinsic
part of
of living a full life um the idea that
they want to destroy that and then say
oh but your children
they're kind of not your children
they're kind of our children and we're
going to teach them some different stuff
in schools
i mean we're seeing the fruits of this
because we know that this stuff
has been being taught on college
campuses for a long time
by the way i get emails from people all
the time now that their kids are being
indoctrinated with this nonsense in high
schools
and the idea that they'll push it down
even further and before you know it
they'll be teaching it in freaking
kindergarten
there is an assault i i don't know how
to describe it any other way guys
there is an absolute assault on
everything that is good and everything
that is american right now
no institution is is
is immune from this okay no institution
has the force field that can stand up to
this thing and
you know as i said in the movie night
last night um
the calvary isn't coming the cavalry
isn't coming you're the calvary
you're the people that have to stand up
in your own way to defend some of this
stuff
because otherwise you're literally going
to send your children to public school
and then
a mafia organization which is
the new york city teachers union
which doesn't even want to teach anymore
i mean in effect they don't even want to
teach they want children to sit at home
on zoom all the time and it's no way for
children to learn i've talked to a lot
of my friends
who are parents i talked to my 10 year
old nephew i mean these poor kids
they're just sitting
my 10 year old nephew actually said to
me the other day uh that he has a
headache at the end of the day from
staring at screens all day long i mean i
play video games with this kid all day
so it's not like he doesn't like looking
at screens
okay not all day but we try to play a
little nba jam every couple days
so the point is we have this new york
city
teachers union which is now injecting
the worst ideas
so it's up to you do you want your
children to be taught by the worst ideas
i guess you can in which case send them
to public school but by the way what do
the democrats also want the democrats
don't want school choice right
they hate they hate the idea of charter
schools
elizabeth warren was always fighting
against charter schools bernie doesn't
like charter schools aoc doesn't like
charter schools you know why they don't
like charter schools
because they want mass indoctrination
centers you know why they want free
college for everybody it's not because
they like free
stuff it's not because they well they
like free stuff but it's not because
they like free education meaning get
a broad education where you might learn
to think what would be the best place to
send everybody
if you wanted to indoctrinate people
well you'd send them to colleges
state-run colleges for free so that they
all come out
as brainwashed marks as socialists
that's what you'd actually do
and that's what they care about so they
don't so while they send their own
children elizabeth warren who's worth
millions and millions of dollars and
also pretended she was an indian at that
job thing you all know about that right
but she's not a racist trump's the
racist uh these people they
they send their own children to private
school gavin newsom
own children in private school virtually
all of these people
these rich elitists who we've somehow
let govern over us
they send their own children to private
schools but you and your children you
pathetic peon
you guys should be indoctrinated by the
nonsense that we're filtering in
lori lori we got work to do okay people
got a long day i think i'm on hannity
tonight i got a couple news max things
over the next couple days
uh you can watch part two of my
interview with abigail schreier which is
out right now the full interview is
already up at rubinreport.com
then my last interview of the year will
be next week with adam carolla i felt
like he was like the right guy to talk
to because he's one of the
few people you know i have a short list
of the people that make sense and he's
in california which is a very short
list of people that make sense uh that
live in california most of them live in
my house actually
uh so adam corolla will be my last
interview for the year and then we're
going to wrap up the year
uh with some best of stuff some best of
interviews that i did on other people's
shows and some of the
some of the best interviews i did and
then next week i'm heading to the
turning point
student action summit and we're gonna
we're gonna post that speech it'll be my
first public speech
in literally a year it was i haven't
done a public speech
in front of an audience since last year
at the very same event because that was
in december
and then in january i didn't have any
speaking gigs and then the the i was
away in february for a little bit and
then the lockdowns began
so i'm super psyched to get out there
and and speak in front of people again i
can't wait for that
so we're going to post that and then i'm
going to try to grab some of the other
people there
and maybe do a couple quick backstage
interviews that kind of thing anyway
have a great day everybody keep
fighting what else are you going to do
right okay
see you tomorrow